mr. Johnson thank you very much for the
interview and welcome on the program
with you some days ago you said that it
is extremely likely that Putin
personally gave the order to use the
nerve agent to attack their former
double spy mr. scree Paul what do you
have as evidence you and the British
Parliament to support this judgment well
I think it's very important first of all
to show that we think the the culprits
for this are not the Russian people not
Russia we have no quarrel with with
Russia and I love Russia and I know it's
you know I have Russian ancestry so if
that's not the the issue the issue was
with the Kremlin and with the Russian
state as it currently is and the reason
I said what I did was because if you if
you look at the the stuff that's being
used it's a it's a nova talk agent
according to our scientists supporting
down there very good we're gonna get the
OPCW in the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons is
coming in today to look at the sample
that we have of the nerve agent you also
have to consider that Sergei scruple the
guy that they attempted to assassinate
is somebody who's been identified as a
target for liquidation and that Vladimir
Putin has himself said that traitors ie
defectors such as mr. screech ow should
be poisoned so it's a Russian only nerve
agent solid evidence that Putin directly
audited because what he said is the most
direct accusation of Russia's leader
ever right well I'm afraid you know he's
in charge of the clattering train as we
say in the UK somebody has to be
responsible somebody has to be
accountable and we in the UK think that
the
evidence points the evidence for
culpability points to the Russian state
and as it did in the case of Alexander
Litvinenko and you remember the trail of
polonium led back very clearly to the
Russian state and in the end mr. Putin
is in charge and that is you know that
I'm afraid he cannot escape
responsibility and culpability why did
you make this statement without waiting
for their outcomes of their
investigation that you are conducting
right now I don't mean you about the
British government well we are giving
the the samples obviously to the
organization to the technical experts
who are coming today and by the way I
have great confidence in them let them
let them decide what they they make of
them they will look at the most they
were look at the move in the best
possible laboratories but I'll tell you
the reason for wanting to to get on with
it is because we have such bitter
experience of what happens with Russia
with Putin's Russia right with with the
Russian state under Putin when we have a
problem like this 12 years ago we had
the assassination in London of Alexander
Litvinenko and at that stage this was an
extraordinary event we had and with
polonium and the UK proceeded with
immense care and slowness and we decided
to work with the Russian judicial system
to to try to extradite mr. Colten and
mr. Lugovoy who were strongly suspected
of having been responsible and in the
end we just got a sort of sneering
sarcastic refusal to engage with our
judicial process and we felt it was very
important to take this decision to get
on to show that if you are going to
recklessly to use nerve agent of a kind
that hasn't been used in Europe since
World War two if you're going to do that
in in Salisbury
in Wiltshire then you've got to face
some some diplomatic consequences and
and that's why we you argue that the
source o far they snuff edge and navi
choke is russia how did you manage to
find it out so quickly
thus britain possess samples of this
well we I I interrogated very closely as
you can this is a face I mean let me be
clear with you I am I wanted when I
became Foreign Secretary almost two
years ago one of my objectives was to
try to reach out to Russia I really did
and I I went to see Sergei Lavrov in in
Moscow against the advice of some people
by the way who said it was a totally
futile venture but I wanted because I
you know I genuinely think Russia is an
incredible country a fantastic place and
it pains me to see the way things have
have got between us
and so I'm genuinely distressed by by
what has happened but when I look at the
the evidence I mean the people from from
Portland on the the labora they have the
samples they do and they and they they
they were absolutely categorical and I
asked the guy myself I said are you sure
and he said there's no doubt so as we
have very different alternative but to
take the action that we have taken but I
must say the difference between this
time and what happened 12 years ago with
Alexander Litvinenko is also that there
is much more sympathy in the
international community far more
understanding of the the kind of
behavior that Russia has been engaged in
in the last few years and round the
table here in in in Brussels talking to
all the other European countries as
there's hardly anybody who hasn't
experienced directly or indirectly some
kind of you know malign or disruptive
behavior it's understandable but in an
interview on sand
you mentioned that you would like to
have a constructive cooperation with
Russia on the EC or how do you see it
having accused Putin directly well yes
and you know as the Prime Minister said
on
I think Monday of last week a week ago
we gave a choice we said look this stuff
is not a chalk if there's a rational
explanation of how it has escaped your
stockpiles and how it has come to be
used on the streets of Wiltshire and
Salisbury then come on that's let's
let's work together and and get to the
bottom of it if on the other hand it
there's no explanation we can only
conclude it's the agency of the russian
state and we got no answer we were
treated with a sort of satirical lots of
sarcastic tweets and crows says that
they would like to have an access to the
case materials will you allow this
access to Russian well I think in the
first instance if I can may respectfully
say to the to the to the Kremlin
detectives I think we will we will trust
to the technical experts of the
organization of the prohibition of
chemical weapons who are here arriving
in the UK today let's see what their
assessment is that's the the proper
procedure that the UK has to follow
under the chemical weapons treaty and
now you know I just have to say that I
find what the Russian position about
what has happened to this knowledge
shock absolutely bizarre increasingly
bizarre you know we're told one that
they didn't make any Nova talk ever
there's one position that they take I
think that the Russian ambassador to the
EU said that second they say yes they
did but all the stocks have been
destroyed the third thing they says yes
they did but all the stocks have been
destroyed except some which escaped to
other countries like Sweden and the
Czech Republic and Slovakia and America
and you know maybe the UK you know I
think they need to make their mind up
about this and
of course if they if Russia if the if
the Putin regime can clarify or explain
what has happened then we are all ears
and were only too willing to listen
the British government denied Russian
diplomats access to us clip I'll who's a
Russian national
well yes what were the reasons behind
this decision
I hesitate to sound protective of well I
just let me just say that to the best of
our knowledge agents of the Russian
state have just tried to assassinate
both Yulia script power and her father
so I think it's all it's our job at
present to to protect them as far as we
can so the British government and Prime
Minister or far the United Kingdom will
have announced some measures and you're
going to expel our 23 or you have
already exposed 23 diplomats from
Britain and you got a symmetrical
response what other measures measures
are going to take what will be the
targets of these measures I understand
that some of them are non-public you
must understand we don't want to do this
out of any particular I don't take any
joy in this so we have expelled 23
diplomats probably spies masquerading as
diplomats and there are other things
that we are going to do and in
particular yes we know we're toughening
up our our borders we have plenty of
laws which allow us to crack down on
money in the UK that has been illicit
Leo Alex plant unexplained wealth orders
right that is money that's been illicit
be or corruptly obtained we can do that
we have the National Crime Agency the
National Economic crime unit can can do
that but I must and they are they will
get on with that work but I must stress
to you that the UK is a a country under
the rule of law and I cannot as a
politician say you know go after that
person's cash do this do that that's not
how it works
you're not going to develop any
like the one that was developed by the
United States the so-called clear
criminal East well we are we're sharing
obviously we share intelligence we share
information we do share lists of people
with with friends and partners around
the world but we operate under the can
you say that so it's a matter for for
the criminal law enforcement agency to
determine whether there is a case to
answer can you say right now that all
officials who work for mr. Putin
including Igor Shuvalov he has a
luxurious property in London that he
will be deprived of his property and the
officials like him I think the most the
the worst thing I could do now given the
work that's going on is get into
individual names or cases because all
these individuals have as you know deep
pockets and very powerful lawyers and I
think I'm sure that almost anything I
said about anybody would be taken to be
prejudicial to any case yeah I will I
will try to put it in another way so you
referred to some Russian businessman as
related to Putin so they might be
punished
what criteria will be applied in
determining that one businessman is
related to Putin and another is not well
I again I think you're inviting me very
very rightly but you're inviting me to
go further in into the detail of such
cases and I think it would be wise for
me to do because all all such legal
actions are open to to challenge under
our system and it's very important that
there should be no there should be no
sign of political bias or interference
and and there won't be you said that you
felt a lot of support from the European
Union and the United States do you think
that these countries will take any
radical measures for example they will
free throw out Russia from the United
Nations Security Council or impose new
sanctions we're laughing well I think
because in order to I think in order to
change the composition of the night
Nations Security Council you would need
a unanimous vote of the Security Council
I think Russia is likely to vote in that
way so you know I think we have already
been very struck and surprised actually
and very encouraged by the strength of
support and the strength of feeling and
the level of sympathy for the for the UK
and what we wanted to do is to work with
our friends and partners sharing
intelligence countering disinformation
mounting defenses against cyber warfare
tracking the money trying as we were
just discussing to crack down on people
who may have a listen Leo Krupp they
obtained their wealth there is all sorts
of work that is now going on but the
objective I must stress this point the
objective is not to punish the people of
Russia at all the objective is to try to
show that we care deeply about the kind
of disruptive and dangerous and reckless
behavior reckless with human life that
we've seen from Russia and that we want
to put pressure on the regime to find a
new path and they can find a new path
and there can be cause for hope but
there won't be cause for hope if we
simply allow this kind of thing to
happen mr. Johnson thank you very much
thank you